these graphs show the depreciated
features of a car using the straight
line method and the declining balance
back bless you
what was the purchase price okay so
that's not so easy purchase price way do
you read it off
yeah good in the linear model in terms
that you already know I guess you'd call
that book y-intercept right that's your
initial that's your start though okay so
purchase price that's V dawn right
that's equal to $15,000 okay reasonable
assumption keep going pot B what's the
value of the car after a year using each
method okay so where's he dear he's our
time axis going down at the bottom right
so a year I'm going to look at these
values here okay so I can see the values
but this is why I wanted a really nice
and big if you squint at yours if you've
got it in front of you you can see
actually these dots right there kind of
approximate right see how each of these
squares is how much each squares a
thousand right so you're at 10,000
11,000 12,000 so on okay so you can see
this blue line which is declining
balance I think we can reasonably say
the declining balance after one year
looks like it's pretty much bang on
11,000
I think that's reason when you get to
the straight line right it's a little
bit sneaky up because I have a think
about it what looks like the best answer
based on what we can see looks like that
12,000 doesn't I think that's reasonable
the graph is not really big enough in
order to get a much more accuracy than
that but just think through this the
consequences over with me okay if it was
12,000 right how much value has it lost
in that first year it went from 15 right
down to 12 so it's lost 3,000 right so
what would you expect it to be the year
after that you went from this
thousand right you go one year down to
12 so then you'd expect it after that to
be nine right is that where it is and
you're like you're looking across and
actually now you can clearly see it off
and the further you go if I go another
year I should be at 6000 right and
you're like oh no I'm Way off I'm way
off so clearly unfortunately for us
12,000 is not the exact value which is
why if you turn into your textbook at
the back it will not tell you 12,000 it
will tell you I think something like
2,200 okay but you need to know like off
this graph you can't really see that all
of these readings are going to be
approximate right but that's okay that's
okay
depreciation is always approximately
just think about this who says that the
car should lose exactly what was it
exactly two thousand eight hundred
dollars per year where does that number
come from it's like oh yeah well there
was that time I bumped into that playing
pole that was five hundred dollars
there's this firm you know the air club
doesn't quite cool the car down quickly
enough that'll be $3,000 whatever right
all these numbers all these numbers are
manufactured right there approximate but
they're pretty clutch they'll give us a
general idea and that's all we need to
do right so in fact I'm quite happy and
within an exam right if you get given a
graph like this then you can say look
the straight-line value right using this
model should really say it's
approximately equal to this and this is
approximately equal to 12,000 I think
that's we did a reasonable amount of
accuracy for this graph okay obviously
if you get more grid lines on it and
more labels you can do it to more
accuracy but I think that's fine next
question when is the car worth $8,000
for each method okay $8,000 that's yeah
okay so if I track across
I actually have a point for that which
is nice and convenient so according to
the declining balance depreciation this
Potsie declining balance it's going to
be after 2 years ok if I go straight
line where am i reading off what do I
have to do where do I have to look on
the graph I'm gonna well sorry let's
wipe it up sorry I'm gonna have to keep
going on I right he's my a thousand
right and it's just gonna keep on going
until I hit the straight line there we
go okay which looks to me like how would
you be then dad two and a half right
so Jesus six months I guess but again
approximately okay when I say that you
know it's a bit funny because we don't
really calculate depreciation on monthly
basically basis anyway we only do it
after a whole year it's no point doing
it oh how much much appreciated this
week it's no point party when is the
book value the same for each type of
depreciation okay so have a look what
point on the graph of my off dog the
intersection right so it looks like well
they're about so where would you call
that something like three years and I
don't know maybe eight months that would
be what would that be
there'll be nine months yeah wouldn't it
because you go three months six months
nine months so it's between six and nine
I call that eight again it's approximate
okay so I'm going to say same
depreciation approximately would we say
three years eight months
and they'll be imagined for error there
which is a separate one okay
okay party when is the greatest
difference in book values now I'm gonna
pause for a second and let you I'll rub
off some stuff from the graph so that
you can see more clearly where do you
think you would interpret this to be the
greatest difference between the book
damage okay hmm
now difference between the book values
right what does that represent what how
would you word that what if you had to
describe to someone I want you to look
for this particular thing on the graph
how would you Fraser what geometric
feature am I looking for yeah I'm
looking for a vertical distance between
the blue and the red right so I'm
looking at these distances one g35
alright so when you put it like that
quite clearly it looks like it's fun
right however the textbook does not say
quiet the textbook actually says now you
you could say six four there's a problem
there right you can see that the
straight line method has already given
you zero dollars and even though the car
might be bad it's not gonna be so bad
that you know you have to pay someone to
get rid of it okay
so therefore this is where it ends right
what they're actually after that says
this is a bit funny right they're
looking for somewhere around here now so
I think their answer is somewhere
between two and a half or three years
okay now here's my question to you um
number one the question is not phrased
correct it could've been phrase more
less ambiguous Lee but why do you think
actually this is where they're
interested and not so much after here
I'm so so okay firstly before the
intercept right so that's important now
why would before the intercept and after
the intercept
why would they mean something to me and
I want you to remember why is
depreciation important to calculate I
had on the board a second ago I just
rubbed it off right for you or me I
would say my car is depreciated this
much and I put it on a form so that I
get up tax refund right that's the whole
point so therefore I want to know at
what point am I going to get the most
benefits right to continue doing it in
this way so it looks like I'm going to
continue getting the most benefit
roundabout here right after this amount
of time and some people might know this
because you know maybe their parents
have done this recently right this point
in time is actually a magical important
time for buying cars right this is a
really important time it's a good thing
to buy cars around this age because
let's put yourself in the position of a
buyer right
you don't want to buy a car over here at
this point in time why not
most expensive I just don't have access
to that money okay but at the same time
you don't want to buy a car over here if
you can help it because that cars really
old and it's bought frightened stopped
working so there's some happy medium in
between where you balance between the
cost and the quality value of the car
right where's that medium spot turns out
to be about here and this is where if
you are if your family has like a
company car or something like that right
companies will often sell their company
cars at this magical spot because
they've depreciated as much as they can
out of it and if they wait much longer
they're not getting much of a tax
benefit okay because this distance is
small right so that's the significance
at this point that's why the answer in
the textbook is actually looking for a
value over here not a value over here
but I think the answer to the question
they phrase it he's five